ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show we are here again for your
viewing pleasure very sad the uh uh
Horses Restaurant in Los Angeles which
I've never been to is closing and it is
a uh tragedy
um chef of Hollywood hot spot horses
accuses husband and co-owner of physical
assault and animal abuse a friend of
mine texted me the inside scoop on why
this is happening and this is a text
that I got you guys I have the scoop on
why horses is closing and it's insane
apparently it'll come out in the Press
soon apparently Liz and Will are 50 50
partners and they had a bunch of cats
and the cats kept dying and they didn't
know why
one day Liz came home to will
masturbating while choking the cat
he had been killing all the cats as his
way of getting off and that my friends
is why horses is closing you heard it
here first apparently he did it to eight
cats
so rip to the horse's restaurant in Los
Angeles they come and they go uh
it's unfortunate we're not going to
spend too much time on that but you know
what I always say sometimes it's good to
move on people have differences of
opinion people have different lives and
Lifestyles and want uh ultimately
different things out of life I think
this man wanted to uh get off while
murdering cats and his wife
um
did not
um she also attempted that he uh tried
to feed the cat to coyotes because he
didn't like it and she said she caught
him violently shaking the cat late at
night whereupon the peptide the next day
we'll put the dead cat in the trash and
insisted on keeping the corpse in the
house Johnson also claims in the filings
that ahajanan it's Persian
uh the mental and physical abuse kept
her from realizing what he was doing to
the cats
it's unclear whether horses is open for
business but and this was good people
like this restaurant yes well what does
one have to do with the other can't they
just get it together and make the food
I mean I understand not wanting to live
with this man but can't they just come
back together to make this food because
a lot of people enjoyed this restaurant
and it's really not fair to the patrons
of the restaurant
responded to the allegations of domestic
and animal abuse he said that he quote
loved cats mice this is terrifying he
loved cats mice and every other animal
under God Allah whatever each religion
calls him her God Los Angeles huh God
Allah whatever each religion calls him
her and have loved all animals since I
was a child he continued by saying I
have problems killing Lobster
and we'll try jerking off and usually
try to do it in the most humane way
possible
also told the times he believed Johnson
was quote trying to take money uh trying
to take my business away from me through
divorce by making up false narratives he
alleged she falsely accuses me of things
she has done or that she has threatened
to do to me and my pets my pets like
children to me and I love them
dearly well that is the sad tale of the
horses restaurant in Los Angeles and
it's a Tale As Old As Time
um Boy Meets Girl
boy opens restaurant with girl
boy adopts cats boy jerks off while
killing cats girl finds out girl gets
angry and it hits the Press
the horse's restaurant in larip
the the violence of the American cities
meant it's got to stop two friends of
mine in New York City they're
trying to get home
two people very private people love
being under the radar
Prince Harry Meghan Markle they're being
chased
in a high-speed chase
all throughout New York City
now many people uh have denied this
happen including the person driving the
car
including the cab driver driving the car
in the New York Post had basically said
uh not really but I get it because these
two and again I'm I'm turning I'm
starting to like them now I for a while
they were annoying to me but now they're
see sometimes when people are in the
Press constantly they become annoying
because they're trying to push a
narrative that we know isn't true like
that they were victims of something
living in a castle and they had no idea
uh what they were getting in she didn't
know what she was getting into I married
his Prince and I'm in a castle and then
the Press wants to see photos of the
baby I had no idea things like that
would happen it's like yes you did you
did you do stop it so we know she's a
fraud she's an actress she's a
cold-blooded serpent so is he there's
Serpentine now
and they're annoying they were annoying
they were annoying and we were sick of
them but we talked about them because
they were fun and then they started to
uh lose relevance of course so what they
did was they cooked up
this thing this false flag where they
were going to try to simulate his
mother's death in New York this I like
this I think is good this is something I
think took creativity it took some type
of planning
um uh we all know that Princess Diana
was killed probably by MI6 who knows
maybe by others but she was dating Dodi
Al fayad and that was a no good no-go
for a lot of the people maybe interested
and maybe the Press killed her in the
tunnel but that there's all kinds of you
know
there's all kinds of inconsistencies and
whatever who knows the world's uh
complex so I don't know exactly who did
it some say am I six the Messiah it's
probably everybody's maybe involved with
that
I don't know but they she died exactly
that way apparently supposedly maybe
kind of sort of being chased by the
Press
so Meghan Markle
and Prince Harry are now putting out a a
false flag attack
the the Press was chasing them all
through New York City in a high-speed
chase that endangered both of them and
it was similar to Harry's mother and
this is a great way for them to get back
into the news and to engender sympathy
which is something they're Addicted to
You know people can get addicted to
sympathy they can get addicted to this
this is a fact I know people that are
addicted to sympathy you ever met
someone who's like parents died and then
after a while you're like enough
it what happens is people get addicted
to sympathy they get addicted to people
feeling bad for them they like walking
into a room and they like the hush tones
of people feeling sorry for them because
it makes them it's two does two things
immediately number one it makes them
interesting because whatever is
happening to them is interesting and
horrible so it makes them a sympathetic
figure but it also makes them
interesting it gives their life uh
something it didn't have before a
meaning of purpose I am the person that
you were to feel bad for I've gone
through so much you wouldn't understand
you could never walk a mile in my shoes
so people really like this feeling and I
would guess and I'm no doctor but I
would guess that Meghan Markle and Harry
certainly Megan I don't know what he's
even doing he doesn't even know either
but Megan has gotten addicted to this
this idea that uh this woman is a
Hollywood actress uh who's on a show
Suits and her life became interesting by
stepping into this role and then
rejecting it immediately and claiming
that she had no idea what it was
um and so then it's but then they moved
here and they released that documentary
on Netflix and it went the other way
they thought well everyone's gonna feel
bad it's like Britney Spears we've let
her out and it went the other way we're
going back Clank because we've now seen
the results Megan and Harry thought they
were going to come to America they don't
understand America America has a
tragically short memory number one so
even if they did come over here uh as
refugees as migrants uh we'd forget
immediately which we did uh South Park
destroyed them the worldwide privacy
tour
um his book you know sold a lot but it
was like a nothing Burger who cares and
people just got sick of them they came
they rented a big mansion in Montecito
uh in Santa Barbara a couple hours north
of L.A and they uh proceeded to be
annoying to Dad a big deal with I
believe Netflix and then there was a
Spotify deal so they came to America
rented a mansion and immediately started
to monetize the horrible things they had
gone through
um and and everybody eventually got sick
of them because it was so crass and
everybody could see immediately what
they were both about they're hucksters
that's what they are and I love a good
huckster there's nothing wrong with a
huckster but we can see it it's it's
right out there in the open for
everybody to see they came here and they
want to hang out and I know people in La
that know them and all they want to do
is hang out with celebrities and I was
at a celebrity party the other night
talking to somebody about this and they
go these people are just it's constant
with them they keep doing she was
texting the person I was with there they
caught and no you can't come but it's I
shouldn't have even been there but the
point is that they just won't stop these
two they were they were to San Vicente
Bungalows they're all God forbid you
stay out of the Beverly Hills Hotel and
I'm eating my souffle for the love of
Christ so help me God so help me [__]
God I see that ginger [__] you stay the
[__] out of the Beverly Hills Hotel it's
probably too old school and conservative
for you anyway stay the [__] out
um but they are Just Like Moths To The
Flame trying to hang out with select
they're like the they're like low-grade
reality stars that are trying to attach
to anything and I'm literally the party
they're showing me text of this woman
begging people to like hang out
she's trying to get places it's sad
and a lot of it isn't working and
they're rolling their eyes to me and
they're going LOL and we're all having a
good laugh about this because they're
just a bunch of goons and no one cares
now listen at the end of the day I
respect the hustle I get what she's
trying to do I get what they're trying
to do but it didn't work right and a lot
of people at this party like hey man you
know we text her back we try to be nice
you know she's The Duchess but we've had
enough right we've had enough of her and
she's you know it's enough so what they
did now in New York City uh the city
um that I lived in for many years my
home
uh they've decided to invent a narrative
where they uh somehow are being
dangerously chased through the streets
just like uh Diana would have been
chased
and the NYPD rained on their parade too
quote the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
arrived at their destination and there
were no reported collisions summonses
injuries or arrests okay the taxi driver
who buried the couple home after their
event Tuesday at the zig Field Theater
told the Washington Post he would not
call it a Chase
adding that he felt safe they got
followed you know why they got followed
because their entire lives are about
sucking all the attention out of
anything that they are involved in
that's why a lot of these people at this
event the other night didn't want them
there and they didn't want to be around
them at other things it's like all they
do is try to suck the oxygen and the
attention out of everything they're
involved in because it's about them and
their cockamami [__] story that the
British royal family was running around
the house with the Noose and it's not
none of it's true it's all uh Canard
it's crap and everyone knows it and so
they're becoming it's becoming like a
it's the she is two years and maybe not
even two years away from being on a real
housewives franchise
she may not want to hear that but sister
friend you and I'm not saying that
because you're blackish I'm not saying
that because you're black I'm saying
that because I use the word sister
friend a lot because it gives me it
feels like a little weight and
credibility and gravity to what I'm
saying I'm not racializing it pleased
out
but I'm saying sister friend that you
are two years away from being on a real
housewives franchise
that's the fact your your tanking in a
major way you're going down
so they invented this uh thing where
they were chased in the high-speed chase
in New York it's uh yeah because there's
seen how to Die Hard where him and her
the NYPD assisted the private security
team protecting the Duke and the
Dutchess a spokesperson said
there were numerous photo photographers
that made their transport challenging
the Duke of the Duchess of Sussex
arrived at their destination and there
were no reported collisions blah blah
blah blah
you know here's the deal
listen to this by the way Harry 38 and
megan41 left the ballroom where the
former suits actress was honored by
Gloria Steinem at the woman of vision
Awards Gala
with her mother Doris Ragland at around
9 50 p.m flanked by both private
security car and NYPD it's going to come
out they hired the paparazzi to do this
by the way soon that's the next thing I
don't know if that'll come out or not
but that's with that's the next step
is that they hired the paparazzi to do
this but
we wish them
well people are mad at the weight loss
drug oh zepik but people are also
celebrating it as a weight loss
breakthrough but also they're saying we
need to fight the fat phobia as well
because ozempic as you know is this kind
of breakthrough groundbreaking drug that
a lot of people are using
the LA Times here and the title is uh
it's a weird cultural moment taking us
epic to lose weight is all the rage but
so is fighting for fat acceptance
so what it basically is saying and
admitting is that people really don't
want to be fat now of course we can't
say that
people would like to be less fat
or not fat but the fat acceptance
movement has convinced everybody to
believe that uh people want to be fat
and that they like being fat they prefer
being fat and that it's a mark of value
or virtue or something else and that by
other people not being uh fat or
whatever it's uh causing them
um
a problem
and this woman Robin
AB carrion
wrote an op-ed here
about that she
you know
she goes and so like many women
I have a dysfunctional relationship with
my weight
I've gained and lost the same 20 pounds
countless times I'm happy when I'm thin
I'm sad and slightly depressed when I'm
not I remain appalled that I pin myself
worth and my appearance
the fat phobia scale asked me 14
questions to determine my beliefs and
feelings about people who were as a
scale put it fat or obese turns out
according to the scale I am fat positive
it praised me as in all bodies are good
bodies Warrior you know
I'm reminded
of
a few things when I read this
am I fat phobic take the quiz I'm
reminded of
I don't
the culture in this country right now
is a series of like odd
quizzes and tests and [__] like
BuzzFeed quizzes like how fat phobic are
you and
if you were a trans superhero which one
would you be
it's it's kind of
it's kind of
like it's it's weirdly like it's
scholarly and yet it's also it's the
antithesis of all things scholarly
you know it's like it's people's an
obsession with grading themselves and
giving themselves grades on how they're
behaving all the time and needing to put
their thoughts and feelings in a box
here's the deal
worry about yourself
worry about the way you want to be
portrayed in the world worry about what
is a realistic way for you to look
try to be better in whatever uh
case that is and try to not pin whatever
your things are on other people
interpersonal fat phobia institutional
fat phobia
I mean it's amazing
there are people that have all kinds of
problems in the world there are drug
addicts there are drunks there are
people that have a bad relationships
with food there are people that are just
fat uh because whatever they've been fat
a long time or they have issues or
whatever the case may be and usually
usually if you can treat people kindly
for the most part you don't [__] on
people and you you don't have to
tell someone they're beautiful if you
don't think they're beautiful this is
the thing if you don't think someone's
attractive you don't have to tell them
they're they're attractive
I think part of the problem is that
we're establishing this
one-size-fits-all
standard for beauty we are we are we are
trying to force
the idea
that aesthetic beauty is a political
thing
I think you know what about beauty is in
the eye of the beholder we've kind of
gotten rid of that
because there are people that certainly
are attractive and overweight there are
people that are skinny and grotesque I
think the ideal is still that you that
bodies that are healthy
and thin
are are are are more attractive to
people that is
usually the case and i i people might
get angry at that when I say that but
that is the case you know
people may not like that but that's okay
it doesn't mean that there aren't
attractive fat people it doesn't mean
there aren't gross skinny meth hats it
just means that like
fat phobia isn't real some people are
dicks some people are dicks and you know
they're they're pieces of [__] to people
that are fat or that are whatever and
those people suck but also calling
yourself a warrior because you're fat is
also stupid
that's also pretty dumb
people in this country used to have
personalities
they did I'm old enough to remember
and as those personalities became these
quizzes
people tended now people now just
identify by what grade on the scale they
are uh of of how racist they are or how
fat accepting or how people used to have
personalities distinct interesting
nuanced personalities that came from
different experiences that they didn't
share with everybody but because
Technology's flattened us all and
culture has become this hellish
landscape of constant self-reflection
and mediation on how I should behave and
what should I oh my God am I the what
scale am I fat phobic I there was a fat
woman on the plane next to me but I
didn't hit her what does that mean
but then you know I did make a face but
I made it to myself like I don't
I don't I don't even understand here
uh what exactly people are supposed to
get out of this stuff
what are people are supposed to get out
of it but those epic does prove
that everybody kind of wants to lose
weight most people want to lose weight
people are not happy being fat nobody's
really happy there are people that have
that are that are okay with it they go
okay it's like most people are not happy
being drunks either
most people are not really happy being a
drunk it doesn't mean that
most people they seem like they're happy
because you only see the when they're
drunk but if you see them the next
morning or sometime the next day if you
see them trying to get the keys out of
their pocket to get into a car uh and
they're just like they're not happy
um people that are in the midst of a
drug addiction or not happy so anything
that throws your life out of balance
you're not really happy
there are a lot of people that are
trying to make it in Vogue to be fat or
that it's the uh you know it's but those
epic proves and a lot of things prove
that people would like to to lose weight
if they could this is a fact that the
fat phobia community and the fat
activist Community doesn't want to hear
that but
those people have invented jobs for
themselves that's not a job being Fat's
not a job you invented a job I don't get
paid because I'm overweight I get paid
to do this
I mean it's not a job they invented a
job and and by the way on on that
I mean to get paid for eating like like
the idea that you're just sitting there
eating and you're like I'm gonna be an
activist and that this Society at this
point is so broken that they fall for it
hey get your bag we'll get a few bags
get the one out of the drive through and
then get the money as well but that's
what we're doing here these are people
that have invented jobs
the person who is riding the fat phobic
quiz should be living in a tent
it's a fact they should be living in a
tent the natural order of things might
be a big tent but they should be living
in a tent they don't it's not a skill
but they've invented a job this is an
economy where we're we're we're
hemorrhaging things for people to do
there's not enough things for people to
do
so the people that just go let me make a
living being aggressively and annoyingly
fat
and let me write quizzes asking people
how comfortable they are with my girth
are getting paid they have a livelihood
that is a livelihood for these people
now
you know
I I just
you know what do you want me to say
about it I'm just like you know
I'd like Meghan Markle better if she was
fat personally like if Prince Harry
married a fat black chick
I would like her more I trust her more
you know
that's just what I'm saying what what
what question on the quiz is that
what's wrong why are they throwing this
doctor out for live streaming operations
I don't like this at all there's a
plastic surgeon and they're they're
trying to get they take her license or
their trying to take her license because
uh
she went viral on Tick Tock and she may
have her medical license revoked can we
play one of her tick tocks yeah
it's uh this woman in Ohio it's Dr
Catherine grah yeah well she's been in
private practice in Ohio since 2010
and she operated out of Roxy plastic
surgery if you were going to a place
called Roxy plastic surgery if that's
the name
your [__] surgeon is going to have a
little pizzazz
and if you don't like it
on social media grows better known as Dr
Roxy
the surgeon who posed behind the scenes
videos but that's fun I want to see the
skin right I want to see a little neck
fat in the in the spit cup or whatever I
want to see that
and people are people don't like she's a
plastic surgeon let her show people the
behind the scenes of what it's like when
people alter their bodies
I don't see anything inherently wrong
with that
has she let's watch some of these things
that she's done that are supposedly so
horrible here we go here we go so these
are all like advertisements too okay
well she's trying to get her back she's
trying to get that money
oh
[Music]
yeah
she puts patience private info on her
public social media but none of them are
identifiable
but three of them are suing wow oh wait
a minute hold on
Dr Roxanne grah who went by the name Dr
Roxy is being sued by three former
patients whose post-surgery injuries
left them unable to stand well that's
different than just posting things like
that I mean that seems maybe that's the
problem it's a combination of both it's
like the medical board like I think yeah
well it doesn't look good if people are
going hey this [__] [__] me up and
then the medical board looks at Tick
Tock and you're just tick-tocking with
the fake tits you know you're
tick-tocking with someone's stomach fat
that you took off and you're like you
know [__]
you know twirling around with it yeah I
mean that's a problem I don't think the
medical board's gonna love that when
you're a [__] uh what's the fortnite
dance that people do oh is there a name
for it I forgot but when you're doing
that and you're swinging people's uh uh
neck sat around it's not good you know
it's not exciting for the people that
can't stand up
I don't know I don't know the name of
the dance is it's it's
immaterial but whatever you can't twerk
with people's fake tits if you're also
going to maim them
yeah she's uh obsessed with social media
and she's trying to get it but she's
just trying to get ahead
she cares more about the camera than the
patient all right
but listen you know she's a plastic
surgeon she's in Ohio she's not the top
of the line right top of the line
plastic surgeon's role in California
right uh where is she is she in Ohio
yeah Ohio she's in Ohio she's the best
you're gonna get Dr Roxy she's just
dancing around trying to get some
attention it's sad Lauren bobert's
getting divorced which is very sad to me
because you know I thought they were
gonna make it and you know Lauren bobert
and her husband represent um the meth
part of Colorado
and I think she owns a bar called
shooters or something or used to work
there where people the girls walk around
like Hooters but they have guns and uh
Lauren bobert and her husband and this
came as a shock to me because I did
think they were going to make it because
she kind of has that Sarah Palin like
white trash where you'd think they would
stick it out but I guess that doesn't
work right
um it's sad
um
because this is like they're a fun
couple like they're
they're constantly like he's constantly
being accused of like uh you know like
uh trying to run over process servers
with his truck and you know they're they
got they got problems the cops are
always there right like she goes uh
bobert says I have been faithful in my
marriage and I believe strongly in
marriage
which makes you know and these are the
people that are always yelling about the
gay people ruining their lives and that
they can't get it together and it's the
Christian Nation and
you know unfortunately now they're gonna
have to dissolve this Godly Union
this Godly Union between Lauren bobert
and her husband uh Jason or something
I forget his name Jason with the Y she
goes this is truly about irreconcilable
differences
she will not comment further on the
divorce quote out of respect for our
children and will continue to work hard
to represent the people of Colorado's
third congressional district
so this is like the person will be like
gay people can't get married because
they're ruining the institution of
marriage but me and my meth had the
husband can't figure it out you know and
again this woman probably has a 90 IQ
right this is the thing that the
conservatives do a lot they pick someone
that is kind of just these this is a you
know this is like our ver like Meghan
markle's way above this woman in terms
of running a scam at least Meghan Markle
got out of the country except she's the
idiot who came back
um but this woman is like the
conservatives found her you know at a
waffle house somewhere and said here
just you know you put the gun in the air
take the tits out and now you can be in
Congress
um but she's fine you know quote uh
Jason bobert was apparently blindsided
when he was served divorce papers last
month and set his uh dogs on the server
according to court documents he was
allegedly quote drinking a tall glass of
beer and cleaning a gun that was sitting
on a table man these people are really
out of like uh they're really at a
Central Casting huh you know yeah I'm
not even Yellowstone these people don't
own land are you nuts
um Yellowstone's like Kevin Costner's
like a CEO and he's like running a whole
thing
and by the way people that are dressing
like the people in Yellowstone please
stop like that's a trend now I've I've
seen that like I've read about that that
like people are like LARPing as Cowboys
it's uh disgusting
um he was drinking a tall glass of beer
cleaning a gun that was sitting on a
table when he was handed the dissolution
of marriage papers well that's sad
he started yelling and using profanities
and told me that I was trespassing that
he was calling the sheriff's office I
told him I was leaving the documents on
the chair outside the door he closed the
door and let the dogs out
who Let The Dogs Out Jason bobert
the
you know Lauren and Jason bobert met
when she was 16 and have four children
together
interesting
well
in a text message statement to The Daily
Beast Jason said the dogs were never a
threat to the server and that he was
upset by the unannounced visit well this
is a good Christian family that has had
some problems and that saddens me it
saddens me because
you know if these kids can't make it
what hope do the rest of us have
um
yeah it's their their fun though I like
I like her because she's like a less
intellectual Marjorie Taylor green like
she's like not as bright it seems like
she's not as like
uh as much of a brain as Marjorie teller
green Lauren broke she's for people who
Marjorie tiller green like the words are
too big they bring out Lauren bobert she
just comes out with the gun and the tits
and everybody's like whoa
and it's sad that she can't that her and
her husband can't get it together
um it said that they just can't find
some common ground they both like the
same things
what are these irreconcilable
differences how different can they be
um
according to bobert's book my American
Life imagine naming a book that my
American Life
my American Life
I had an American life it's it's
American
she and Jason met when she was 16 and
working at a Burger King these are the
people I want running the country I want
Burger King employee white ones white
people that were white and worked at
Burger King that they didn't really
suffer too many disadvantages in their
life but they still ended up making
Whoppers uh that's who I that's who I
think should be in Congress and I'm
sorry if you don't
I like it you learn a lot at a Burger
King you know you learn a lot
Lauren bobert and her husband Jason and
people are gonna get mad at me they're
gonna be like she has good values you're
a piece of [__] you're in L.A she's got
good value she worked at Burger King
I you know
I think he was classy right what did he
say because I love her too much is
anything bad about her she's a mother of
my children and my partner for the last
20 years please let me just have some
peace well hey I I agree
I agree with him on that
in in February 20 2004 Jace was booked
on a domestic violence charge against
his future wife after he did unlawfully
strike shove and uh kick her well
listen she could be a bit mouthy
but I mean this is a Christian family in
which occasionally there has to be a
strike a shover a kick I believe
occasionally
oh in in May 2004 the couple got into an
altercation at Jason's home in which
Lauren scratched his face and chest and
trash his residence
she was slapped with third degree
assault criminal mischief and underage
drinking charges
they're fun they got married in Vegas of
course they got married in Vegas what
did they have the royal wedding
she was a Teen Mom and forced to drop
out of high school during her senior
year when she was pregnant with Tyler
this is the family values that they keep
talking about I like I I like to see
them in action Teen Mom multiple
altercations and then finally a divorce
it's the good family values that I like
so
we are fans of the boberts we've always
been fans of the boberts we think it's
great
um that they're here for us and we're
saddened by them and we hope the divorce
is incredibly public for the sake of the
show not for the sake of their family
that would be sad but for the sake of my
program I hope the divorce is incredibly
long vicious and public because it will
give me content because that's what I do
for a living Sorry
so and as she hates gay people so she
hates me so I hope the divorce is long
in public and it involves many more
altercations and many more brandishing
of firearms and releasing of dogs
because I get bored on planes and I like
to read this [__] so I hope it is a
public and vicious divorce uh in which
uh a lot of fun Secrets come out and
there are weapons involved and I hope
many process servers are maimed [__]
them too uh in the process that would
make me very happy uh but I I but it
would be sad for the kids so if that
maybe not for the kid even though the
kids it might be tough anyway but that's
my selfish hope because unfortunately
that's what I do for a living Sorry
two is unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
Viagra Cialis and Levitra but an
intuitable tablets at a fraction of the
cost you could take them any time day or
night so you could plan ahead or be
ready whenever an opportunity Rises the
process is simple sign up at
bleacher.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription with the day is the best
part it's all done online so no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations in the waiting line of the
fun it's dick bills you need them get
them Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA and prepared to Ship Direct to your
door in a discreet package I know people
who use it and they love it Lucci wants
to help you have better sex discover
your options at bluetooth.com chew it
and do it everybody likes Bluetooth that
I know everybody uses it it's all good
my whole family uses it we all take it
together at Christmas
um
gotta go to bluetooth.com promo code TD
you get your first month free that's a
great deal bluetooth.com more details
and important safety information
um the best part all this is done online
folks you don't really have to do
anything here you just go online it's
amazing it's prescribed to you it's
perfect it's beautiful
um we thank Bluetooth for sponsoring the
podcast let's play this Walt Disney
World fight video because it's
call it the magic King started over a
photo op one family didn't want another
family to take a photo or something or
they ask them to move and then both
families started beating each other in
the Magic Kingdom
[Music]
right now on the news engine 6 fist
flying at Disney World a family photo
shoot turns into an all-out brawl there
at the Magic Kingdom this happened right
in front of the train where you first
entered the park great welcome I'm John
Brown and I'm Luanne and Sorel one
family was trying to take a picture when
another family apparently got in their
way Fox 35 Stephanie balfabonti is live
at the park tonight and Stephanie that's
apparently when these families started
duking it out
yes it is and for people visiting the
most by the way can you stop this for
saying
the newscasters now
just like I remember when a newscaster
used to dress like newscasters look like
they found people on the street and gave
them microphones
like
I don't know what happened to
newscasters like even when someone was
in the field they used to look
professional they used to dress
professionally like they would be
quaffed and the hair would be done now
it really looks like they're just
finding people
sitting in their car and going would you
mind doing this News segment for us in
the middle of the highway
I just don't like every chick has a 9 19
dress on
and like fake jewelry badly applied
makeup the dudes are like weird [__]
looking guys their hairs all over the
place they're sweating they're it just
is does not give me any comfort but
let's let's see what happened to these
two families I hate when there's
um
family uh fights during a a vacation
that's meant to be a special as a Disney
World on Earth wasn't looking so magical
when they were trying to get into the
park and they saw that bloody fight
traffic
in a chaotic scene you can see deputies
on the ground arresting a man after a by
the way look at the people just freeze
frame on that can you freeze frame on
that can you freeze frame on what who
the people are at Disney World
I would I tell my friends who have
children I go don't do it I know that
they they love Disney whatever I'm
telling you there's got to be other
things look at the human beings that are
at Disney world I mean it's just
it is just a parade
of of of heinous creatures right people
at the park screaming
creatures
[Music]
play it because I love I love hearing
the screams
because it's so funny
[Applause]
how do these people have the money to go
to Disney World who's paying for that
because no offense but this by their
behavior it seems like they these don't
seem like the type of people that have
saved for a family trip
I could be wrong I'm not saying that
people don't get into skirmishes but
it's kind of like
is that what goes on in Disney World is
it just like it's a kind of a mad house
of all kinds of different people but a
lot of garbage like a lot of human filth
running up in there
and this all started over a photo op in
front of the Magic Kingdom they're just
beating each other I don't know where
their children are
I love the idea of like Rhonda Sanders
he's like you know Disney's getting too
gay or trans or whatever and like kids
being like my parents beat each other
over a photo op you know kids are like
listen we got a lot there's a lot of
problems
um
yeah I mean listen I mean Disney World
is going to attract the the wide variety
of people we have in this country 90 of
whom uh uh you know probably should uh
you know not be allowed in there should
be a screening process to get into
Disney World
there should be a screaming process to
uh bring your children into Disney World
someone should sit down and interview
you
um for a minute and go like uh just out
of curiosity how apt are you to engage
in a brawl what would get you what would
get you to the level where you have to
get into a brawl with someone yeah what
would do it let's say you were taking a
photo and somebody uh bumped into you
would that what would that turn into a
melee
that turn into me because we're trying
to cut down on these vicious beatings
we're trying to cut down on the Gangland
style vicious beatings here at Disney
world it's bad it's bad we've got a lot
of problems you know we've got uh many
issues here uh people saying we're uh I
don't know getting a little too woke
also we are uh you know so what we'd
like to just scale down on is the gang
assault
if we could
if we could I I'm telling right now I I
don't want to step in Step foot in the
Disney World
is there one in China
because I'll take my godsend to the one
in China and like I'll pay for his
family we can all go but I will not go
to the one in uh Shanghai Disneyland
Park bring that up we will go to that
I will go to Shanghai Disneyland park
that looks dope as [__]
by the way try to have a brawl there
that's creepiest [__] but cool
Shanghai Disneyland Park's probably the
answer because if you have a brawl there
you just disappear or you work there you
start working there
Shanghai Disney park is just full of all
their employees or people that
previously had brawls there and they
just go yeah I work here now I'm not
allowed to leave now I can't go but I
will go to that I'm not going to subject
my uh Chinese godson to these American
monsters I will take him to Shanghai
Disneyland park with his family and I
gotta be honest with you it looks kind
of cool
it looks pretty damn cool
I may do my next special from China Tim
Dillon live from China
I'll be the first American to defect
yeah Shanghai Disneyland park looks fun
that looks like the move for me
everybody uses expressvpn and if you
don't you're in the minority and you
gotta switch to it it doesn't take much
technical knowledge to hack somebody
just some cheap Hardware is needed a
smart 12 year old could do it your data
is valuable hackers can make up to a
thousand dollars per person selling your
personal info to the dark web
why use expressvpn I mean come on dude
they put everything into an encrypted
tunnel it creates like a secure tunnel
between your device and the internet
hackers cannot steal your sensitive data
it's super secure it it'd take a hacker
with a super computer over a billion
years to get past expressvpn's
encryption it's easy to use fire up the
app and click one button to get
protected it works on all devices phones
laptops tablets and more so you can stay
secure on the go I use it everyone I
know truly uses vpns a lot of people I
know are on Signal and like I guess it's
Telegraph or something or telegram I
don't know but the point is that people
are becoming more aware of how they're
surveilled not only by the governments
but by uh different you know companies
marketing agencies stealing your data
harvesting your data selling it it's you
know you're getting marketed to all the
time and getting annoyed you know unlike
this which is an ad
um but you know it's it's crazy
so I think that you have to just protect
yourself it's like you don't leave your
house without a gun
so why would you go on the computer
without expressvpn
it's easy to use it's it's not a big
deal you don't have to do any of the
coding you can just get in there
secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com Tim Dylan that's
expresvpn.com Tim Dylan and you get an
extra three months free expressvpn.com
Tim Dylan restaurants uh dining is going
to the dogs and not everybody is happy
about just in time for summer dining
scene the US government has given its
blessing to restaurants who want to
allow pet dogs in their outdoor spaces
here's the thing man I I I'm telling you
right now man I love dogs I love animals
cut it out we have to stop this
um it's it's it's it's not right it's
really not right I've seen and first of
all the service dog thing we all know
it's fake we all know it's fake everyone
knows it's fake if you are not blind we
know it's fake you don't need a dog on a
[__] plane don't get on the plane if
you can't handle it we all know it's
fake okay literally people tell me they
go I yeah I got my doctor wrote me a
note I can take it anywhere we know the
game we know the game Meghan Markle it's
like it's the same thing as that it's
like we know it's not real it's not real
it's not doing it it's not a service dog
sitting on your lap it's not serving
anything it's not doing it's not a Saint
Bernard going down the mountain and
rescue and they never did that by the
way if you read about it they never
really rescued anyone now it's still a
phenomenal uh you know Majestic breed
but they didn't rescue anybody and they
had there's a little booze in the thing
that was for drunks people that wanted
booze the dog would bring them booze
it's different than rescuing my point is
this we got to get the dogs out of all
the spaces here because people are just
trying to Chomp down on an eggs benedict
they just don't need your mutt like
leave it home leave it in the yard
stop replacing have a kid
you know like stop putting the dog in a
stroller it's it's a sick fetish with
the animals at this point
it's enough
you're not a dog mom a cat Mom it's it's
gross if I'm eating outside or at a
restaurant or inside of the restaurant I
want you to keep your animals away from
me
I want you to keep your animals at Bay
I'm telling you right now it's like
it's just gross
that you can't do anything without the
dog there
you can't you know you're feeding the
dog there was a dog I was in LA conda
Verdean Tribeca it's a great restaurant
there's a dog like tied they tied the
leash around the leg of the chair it
can't even move and it's sitting under
the table
and she said she doesn't even have the
decency to give him a meatball and I
wanted to go up to her and be like why
are you out of your house right now with
this dog
I just and I saw this happen you know
when I was living in New York City I
really saw the beginnings of this and I
saw how how crazy this was gonna get
I saw it and I saw how how you know
people really started connecting you
know after 9 11 everybody kind of got a
dog there was nothing wrong with that I
love dogs I think dogs are great I think
cats are great I think
animals are great but I think things
have their place animals have their
place right
walk them bring them to Parks they don't
need
to sit at a restaurant Courtyard if
there's you know in the spring in the
summer in the fall an outdoor restaurant
is still a restaurant
it is still a restaurant okay it's not
another thing well it's the outside
section it's a restaurant it just
doesn't happen to have a roof get the
animal out of here do not have an animal
on a you know a leashed or Unleashed
sitting under the Ted these animals are
miserable they don't want to be there
please take them home
it's sick
I'm telling you I would just I would
just if I owned a restaurant I'd love to
one day I would just say no like you
it's not gonna happen
you can't
consistently impose your life on other
people
you know and I know that people think
like it's some like civil rights issue
because that's how [__] sick we are
as a country people think their civil
rights are being denied
if they can't bring a [__] dog to
have brunch
they think like they're being denied
some meaningful
part of their thing it's like
you know there was a Pakistani Uber
driver once I said to me I see he goes
we have many dogs in Pakistan I don't
know if I'm doing I don't I don't know
if I'm doing it but it was similar to
that it was we have many dogs in
Pakistan
was that it we have many
[__] I'm so bad
because it's like
Pakistan and we have many dogs
now I'm going Indian but I don't want to
go anywhere he's just Pakistan but they
are so close but anyway he said I'll say
in my voice but he said we have many
dogs in Pakistan and I go what are their
names and he goes they don't have names
they're dogs which I thought was great
I actually thought that was interesting
because right like yes that's a little
extreme but I understood what he meant
I'm like right my grandfather said there
were dogs in his house he didn't barely
know the names and he was growing up I'm
not saying you shouldn't love your dogs
and he remembered one or two of the dogs
names but it's like we've gotten to a
point now where even the dogs want to
know what's going on with these freaks
that are taking them everywhere even the
dogs are like what am I why am I on a
plane
like you know a dog should be on a plane
like once in their life they're like oh
my yeah this dumb [__] just got a job in
Phoenix
so I gotta fly
I'm flying to Phoenix because the the
[__] [__] who adopted me broke up
with her boyfriend I got her
and she just got a job there I don't
know she's doing something for Baseball
spring training she'll probably [__]
everyone she's a [__]
and now I gotta fly to Phoenix with her
but that's it then I get dropped off
then I'm done
the dog shouldn't have Delta Sky miles
like it should be enough like they
shouldn't be on every flight
people that impose like
people that act like it's not an
imposition to have like what if everyone
brought their dog does anyone think like
that like what if all people were to
bring their dogs to the restaurant The
Outdoor restaurant and every single dog
is there
I mean doesn't anyone think that that
might potentially lessen the experience
for people if we just constantly I'm
walking over your dog I'm just trying
you know what I mean like can't people
understand how deeply selfish it is and
that this unhealthy
um you know reliance
that they have on this animal is like
really it's it's kind of disturbing to a
lot of people
that they can't do anything without this
dog and I'm not saying you shouldn't
love your dog but like
cut it out like cut it out I'm a single
person without children you can be alone
there's a dignity and just not trying to
Force an animal to be your boyfriend or
girlfriend or child
there's a dignity to it there's a
dignity to to be to Solitude if you can
pull it off
there's a little dignified way to do it
I've eaten in restaurants alone I've
seen other people do it there's a real
dignity too
not
carrying in your fur baby or whatever
disgusting name you have for the dog I'm
not saying you shouldn't love a dog I'm
not saying the dog shouldn't be part of
your life I'm not saying you can't love
it like a child although it's not but
I'm not saying you can't I don't care
what you do in your private life get it
out of the restaurant is my point
there's a dignity in learning to be
alone especially at certain points in
your life you actually have to learn to
be alone people right now because of
phones and adopted pets and group chat
like no one's ever alone with their
thoughts everybody the amount of people
I got out of every group text by the way
the amount of people I know that have 19
group texts constantly buzzing in their
phone where they cannot have a single
solitary thought without it being
co-opted and corrupted by five other
people
it it's it's it's insane to me you need
to learn how to be alone with your
thoughts in this world and I know it's
not nice because many of those thoughts
are negative because life is negative
sometimes and you're but you're never
gonna have any meaningful breakthroughs
in your life if you can't shut off the
noise of the group text or the internet
or you can't go anywhere without a dog
sit now listen there's exceptions to
this go to the bakery and sit down with
coffee you got a dog I'm not a Nazi
about this I'm saying you know more
often than not in an outdoor restaurant
we just don't need your animal
and I'm saying that like people need to
learn one of the things I've seen that
it's actually kind of disturbing these
people just don't know how to be alone
anymore and be chill
they don't know how to chill when
they're alone they're either creepy or
they're sad looking or they look like
they need help
be alone yeah the dogs at home I I was
hungry
I came out to have now then there's the
people that are gonna would the couples
that bring the dog that's sick
the only people I feel bad for in this
scenario are the lonely [__]
who come in with a dog if you are a
group with a dog burning house a burn in
hell if you're a couple with a dog [__]
off
the only people I'm even trying to
relate to here and reach are the lonely
people who feel like being with a dog
helps them deal with uh being lonely
those are the only people I'm trying to
talk nicely to here the groups of people
that bring dogs in should be turned away
I'm only trying to reach the lonely
people who think that just because
they're alone they are like I don't know
conspicuous or they stand out or it's
just better to have a I'm just more
comfortable with my dog here with me I
just don't it just you just you need you
need to learn to be by yourself you need
to learn to fly on a plane without the
dog you need to learn what it's like to
have a chicken Caesar salad without a
dog you need to learn that there's a
dignity in being alone if you can do it
at a restaurant we're talking about
being in a restaurant we're talking
about eating alone in a restaurant
there's always great like a great older
woman with a nice glass of chardonnay
and the way she'll sit and she'll pick
it a salad yes she's it was an anorexic
yes our life's horrible but in that
moment there's a strong dignity to that
she's trying to choke down just enough
food to survive she was a you know maybe
a ballerina back in the day and she fell
in love with one guy and he was a drunk
and he they couldn't figure it out and
and life has been very unkind to her
um she's white that helps you know but I
mean but it's been very because they get
more stuff but life's been very unkind
to her and it's but in that moment with
her glass of chardonnay and her side
salad there's a dignity there to eating
alone there's a dignity to the the kind
of portly man who sits alone at the bar
eating and being a little chummy with
the bartender there's a dignity to that
if you know how to do it the kind of uh
pleasantries they share
um you know how how are you have you
been how's your son he's good my son is
good you know and just we haven't seen
you in here in a while you know and
that's a joke because he's in all the
time they go oh I haven't seen you in a
while he goes yeah I know I'm here a lot
he's here a lot because his wife's dying
his wife's dying and it's hard for him
to face and he'll never forgive himself
for how little time he spent with her uh
in the last moments but but there and
it's sad that he can't face up to that
and he can't face up to her death
because it makes him think about himself
and his own mortality and his son will
never forgive him for it because it's a
very hard thing you should have been
there more with her you know and and why
weren't you there with her why were you
always at that bar and then those are
horrible things but there's a dignity
there's a dignity in that moment when
they give him the burger and he cuts it
in half when he cuts that burger in half
there's a dignity to it yes he's running
away from everything in his life the
only woman that really ever loved him
but she doesn't even hold it against him
because she was always stronger than him
and she knew that you know he was kind
of a near do well
um but there's a dignity in that moment
there's a dignity in certain moments
that will be ruined if if he had a big
Shaggy Dog next to him the the moment
would be ruined there there wouldn't be
a dignity in that there's I think a
dignity in eating alone I've seen people
do it the right way
and no one's doing it because they look
you know there's just a dignity
especially in New York City it's a
religion eating alone in New York is
religion
people do it all the time it's great you
watch the restaurant you watch how
everything happens you see the rise in
the fall you see the servers struggling
to keep up with how busy the
restaurant's getting and they're
frenetic and angry and they're dropping
things and you're just kind of quietly
watching them eating and just kind of
watching the whole restaurant where it
kind of spins out of control
um you know there's there's something
really fun about that and I think that
like people just need to learn that
um instead of just you know constantly
dragging these dogs or the dog doesn't
want to be there man
the dog does not want to be there at all
Bud Light to launch camouflage bottle
amid transgender controversy
um you know Bud's now trying to go uh
the other way Miller lied to the weird
thing too I mean Rogan were texting
about it he played it on his show about
how like it was horrible that women
the Miller Lite which is like piss beer
and they're trying to sell it to like
horny dudes who are trying to look at
tits and they're like well women like
can you believe they put women in
bikinis to sell this product like yeah
it's a bad product it's not a great
product
yeah it's sex cells is this new
but apparently they did something on
Miller lie I I don't understand what's
going on people that are drinking
American Beer it's like yeah it's
they're selling you garbage they're
gonna sell it with some tits
attached to it that's that's who do you
think's drinking beer well Miller Lite
it's you know Bud Light what do you
think is consuming this aficionados
this isn't for the craft beer heads it's
like [__] guys that are like oh yeah
let's go get [__] similar I just saw
this commercial with a couple of chicks
and bikinis were almost hooking up I I
feel like I'm going to get Miller now
the Bill Hicks did a little bit about it
about how much six
sex cells where it's like a model
fingering yourself and she's like buy
coke like I mean it's like
so now they're saying uh they're going
the other way it's an aluminum bottle I
believe it is the only package it will
be transitioning I'm not sure and it's
going to be the company set to launch a
line of camouflage aluminum bottles that
promote the folds of Honor program which
provide educational scholarships for
families have fallen and disabled
American military service members and
First Responders in New York Post
reported
I mean wow
they've gone the other way huh
wow
jeez
so now they're doing
now they're doing like
it's nice you should have done that
anyway to give First Responders things
we didn't you didn't need to have an
uproar
um
I just wonder how Wild it'll get you
know
like how you know
you know will they start having
commercials like some shade of Hitler
was a bad guy
but we see is a man that cared about his
country
Bud Light
I mean it's like how
how Wild will it get you know
Nathan Bedford Forrest starting in an
organization called the Knights of the
Church of the Klu Klux Klan
and while that con that organization has
been controversial here in Heartland
we remember when your daddy went out and
he grabbed his hood the only thing he
took with him other than a torch was a
can of Bud Light
Heil Hitler Bud Light
Bud Light believes that every American
family has a right to defend their
Homeland from Invaders coming across the
border illegally
this is a white country Bud Light
Bud Light believes that European values
Built America you keep your guacamole
and your queso
we'll take God faith family and freedom
but line whites only
like
how crazy will it get you know
some people think it was six million
but
but here at Bud Light we haven't seen
the numbers
we're simply saying that history is
never what any one person thinks Bud
Light
find your own number
find the number you're comfortable with
you know bud lights hurt a lot about
diversity being America's strength
but if you look at the shapes of
people's skulls they're different
but like stick with your own
in an exclusive partnership with 4chan
or is this called now eight [__]
but that's what it's called it's not
Bud Light is here to recognize the
Warriors in the battle for free speech
and free expression
that's why
every commemorative can of the Bud Light
will feature the happy Merchant meme
and if you don't like it and [__] off
hmm
you're at Bud Light we're a little sick
of hearing about bankers
transnational Bankers that don't give a
[__] about you they just want the
interest on your Goddamn money what
happened to making a living with your
hands instead all this financial mumbo
jumbo
Bud Light watch out for bankers
uh Bud light's getting Flack for its new
cam
uh which shows
uh the um a militarized border wall
people standing outside
Bud Light believes this country should
be protected
I'll sick dogs on them I'll Point guns
at their little heads I don't give a
[__]
this is our party
and it's closed Bud Light I mean that
may be the way they have to go
why not why not just get get a little
fun
get a little fun
Bud Light believes Brittany grinder
should have been left in Russia
but LA Police play stupid games Win
stupid prizes
Bud Light supports Russia
in its war against the globalist Ukraine
Bud Light
the evil you know
Bud Light sinks there's a lot of Chinese
Communists out there making your kids
trans but you know what we do here at
bloodline
we promote traditional wholesome
American values
like questioning why Israel had uh art
students
doing weird surveillance things by the
Twin Towers a few days before anyway
Butler
[Music]
Bud Light uh
timberlandcomedy.com amazing shows
coming up this weekend uh we're they're
happening they're happening right now is
this episode's coming out
so [__] you you missed them in
Charleston and Hershey PA
um
we are a few tickets left for the
Chicago Theater one of the greatest
places the Duke comedy in the world also
the Masonic in San Francisco I will be
there I'm also going to be in Vegas in
Las Vegas Nevada
uh we're Saturday July 22nd The Encore
at the encore theater at Wynn Las Vegas
uh Saturday July 22nd I'm in Colorado
July 27th through the 29th at Comedy
Works South
um and then Parks Casino in Pennsylvania
in September that we may add some other
things as well
um but the Vegas shows are going to be
really fun I have not performed in Vegas
in a very long time I'm very excited
about that Tim dilloncomedy.com for all
your tickets thank you good night to
everyone except Meghan Markle